[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
el retorno hacia venezuela fue la salida
para al menos 130 mil migrantes tras el
colapso económico causado por la
pandemia de kobe 19 sin más opciones
miles cruzaron las fronteras de vuelta
en venezuela los esperaba una cuarentena
obligatoria en centros de atención para
contener posibles casos positivos del
virus sin embargo el aislamiento pasó de
14 días hasta más de 70 para algunas
familias permanecieron encerrados en
lugares que carecían de las condiciones
básicas para su saneamiento en situación
de hacinamiento con escaso acceso a
alimentos y mínima atención médica
quienes se quejaron por dichas
condiciones fueron amenazados con ser
detenidos y los retornados denunciaron
que las autoridades de su propio país
los recibieron bajo condiciones hostiles
a estas conclusiones dijo human
rightswatch el centro de salud pública y
derechos humanos y el centro de salud
humanitaria de la universidad johns
hopkins tras un rastreo de la situación
de los retornados así nos lo explicó el
director para las américas de human
righs watch josé miguel vivanco
miren los retornados venezolanos saben
que las normas generales consisten en
que deben someterse a una cuarentena
cuando regresan a venezuela lo que no
saben es que esa cuarentena consiste en
en una virtual detención y mariah
detención arbitraria para que han
sometido ciento a 130.000 140.000
personas en condiciones insalubres y
donde no hay medidas higiénicas básicas
muchas veces con total hacinamiento
donde hay brotes de coronavirus aunque
parezca sorprendente
y realmente sufre en un plato
perfectamente que se puede calificar
como como inhumano como cruel y al mismo
tiempo las autoridades venezolanas
empezando por el propio maduro no se
califican a estos ser retornados como
armas biológicas los tratan como si
fueran enemigos traidores
lo cierto es que en la práctica es una
situación dramática
donde sus derechos básicos no han sido
respetados pero además de las malas
condiciones en las que pasan su
cuarentena preocupa que estos centros de
aislamiento más que lugares para evitar
la propagación del virus sirvan de caldo
de cultivo para el cob y 19 una de las
cuestiones más dramáticas que pudimos
documentar en este informe es
precisamente la situación de aquellos
que retornan a venezuela están sanos que
no tienen el virus pero que lo contraen
en el minuto en que en que regresan a
venezuela y que son así a sintomático
que no presentan ningún rasgo del virus
son sometidos muchos de ellos casi todos
como una práctica a un test que no es
confiable un test de verificación del
virus que arroja altos porcentajes de
falsos negativos y esos junto a otros
están concentrados además en unos sitios
como que como ya dijimos son insalubres
en hacinamiento si las menores
condiciones de higiene y allí
precisamente retornados que eran sanos
contraen el virus
y padecen todas las consecuencias
obviamente de lo que esto significa en
condiciones muy precarias y mientras la
situación es crítica en los lugares de
cuarentena no cambia cuando los
retornados logran salir de ellos la
crisis generalizada en venezuela tiene a
cientos de nacionales buscando
soluciones por esto en las fronteras se
mezclan quienes buscan retornar a su
país empujados por la crisis en el
exilio y personas que quieren emigrar
impulsados por la pobreza y en otros
casos por el trato que han recibido tras
retornar aurora bayou 2 cuenta más
[Música]
nuevamente y caminando tras la
reapertura económica de colombia miles
de venezolanos buscan atravesar la
frontera que sin embargo sigue cerrada
por el cui 19
en caminata
hay gente en la calle que nos ha tendido
la mano
dejamos con la gracia de dios y idish
colmenares es una de ellos camino hizo
autostop 800 kilómetros hasta la ciudad
fronteriza de san cristóbal con sus tres
hijos del monte y para dormir en el piso
obviamente este año al menos 100 mil
venezolanos regresaron a su país cuando
la pandemia cerró los negocios y dejó a
los vendedores informales sin poder
ganarse la vida muchos dicen que fueron
estigmatizados por el gobierno a eso se
suma el recrudecimiento de la crisis en
venezuela con la inflación la escasez de
alimentos y la falta de acceso a
combustibles adultos no podemos aguantar
cinco años que no tiene nada en sus
casas que no tienen un alimento
allá donde llega el momento de la
desesperación las autoridades
migratorias de colombia intentan impedir
las entradas irregulares y advierten que
el país podría llegar a albergar unos 2
millones de migrantes venezolanos en los
próximos meses
al tiempo que los migrantes venezolanos
comienzan a caminar de regreso a
colombia a través de cruces informales
para el tema de los retornados human
righs watch y la universidad johns
hopkins recomiendan a los países de
américa latina a abordar de manera
urgente la situación humanitaria de los
que viajan de vuelta a venezuela hasta
que inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
siga conectado con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]